what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are in Chicago we're gonna be talking
about the future of Education and we're
with Davis Jones what's up man hi thanks
pleasure I'm excited appreciate it
watched your content in the past I know
that you're gonna challenge us to think
differently and I think I'm excited
about that I think you already have
you've already challenged yourself think
differently about education and you've
built a company around it ezel ezel co e
AZ Elko right here go and check them out
and we'll be talking about of course
what they're up to and in general kind
of the evolution of Education over time
and where we're headed and yeah let's
start unpacking this so all right we are
so grateful that we evolved on this
planet now we have consciousness we have
all these buildings we have this
education system ubiquity water food
electricity all these cool things and
something that has been evolving over
time is the way that we teach young kids
and we've went from I'd kind of like to
like I think it's a good time to insert
that education has changed a lot because
it's a lifelong pursuit now particularly
with technological disruption and
specifically 54% of people who enroll in
basically higher education courses and
programs in the United States there now
what we call independent learners which
means that they are financially
independent of their parents they tend
to be over 24 they usually have families
they have jobs so the whole concept of
education as a young person's thing is
kind of out the window now
I like how you brought that up and
especially because it's the love of
learning
I believe it's phyllo math the love of
learning and the just importance of
lifelong learning that this is not
something that goes on from 0 till 18 or
0 to 22 and then you're done this is
something that you're
constantly loving learning insatiable
curiosity this is it right to just be
like like actually I think that Buddhism
has a fantastic metaphor for this
Buddhism talks about the garden of your
mind
and I've often had fun meditations
imagining the garden of my mind and how
beautiful it is to have beautiful
statistics knowledge and beautiful
technology knowledge and history
knowledge and sociology knowledge and
all those things developing in the
garden of your mind I really love the
garden of the my analogy because it
really does take planting seeds and then
watering them over time to gain the
knowledge and have those flowers blossom
throughout life and occasionally you'll
get a massive tree which is when you go
really hard if studying a specific field
of knowledge your garden or whatever
it's not like something you can just
leave alone it's a lifelong pursuit of
making your inner self and your inner
mind really beautiful and diverse and
lush yes yes and so so right so we kind
of evolved to teach kids at young ages
about things like language how we can
talk to each other things like how to
use certain tools and so we ended up
kind of evolving with that until let's
just jump all the way to I mean we had
music and writing and you know reading
and and then we got into a lot of the
Scientific Revolution happen during the
Renaissance period so we got into a lot
of the macro scale and micro scales of
the sciences chemistry's biologies
physics and soon now we kind of see
ourselves with the educational system
infrastructure that's still here from
the post-industrial revolution the
purpose of the university a purpose of a
university was really to be a place
where physical books could be collected
when they were expensive and primarily
they were around to educate theologians
who are gonna go back and be clergy
people in places not in the university
and the idea was that if you had these
beautiful libraries then you could have
access to all the world's knowledge
obviously that's not the situation we're
in
more with the beauty of the internet and
information being so readily available
it's just we don't necessarily need
physical books as much as maybe they did
in the you know 16 17 18 19 centuries
initially the purpose of the university
was this massive collection of books for
people to be able to go and access and
gain all because books were so expensive
right I mean back you know I don't know
I don't know I'm not a book historian
but I mean you're talking you know
pretty significant significant
investments to get a book in 1600s right
and so that meant that education was not
accessible to everybody and so as a part
of making it accessible it was like why
don't we all gather here we can share
these books and then education is more
widely available and that's really the
the reason that universities began and
then the clergy people would go and be
the smartest person in their village or
whatever and they would help instruct
people about living their lives based on
the philosophies and the beautiful
things they learned at university so
cool ok so then this was around the
sixteen hundreds if you have to look I
mean I'm pretty sure the oldest
university in the world is in live and
in Belgium and I believe if I'm have to
pull something out of my booty you'd be
probably in the in the 17th century I
would imagine that was established I'm
sure your audience will help me to
account on that if I'm incorrect but
yeah so those are the earliest ones I
mean I believe Harvard in the United
States and Yale these are late 19th
century maybe mid 19th century here in
the u.s. there might be some older than
that I'm not totally positive but you
know that's kind of the the timeframes
you're looking at ok so now the general
idea for the four children ended up kind
of evolving around like let's say
whatever 1850 1900 this just general
idea of okay you get some literature you
become literate you get some history you
get some math you get some science
rarely did we teach things like
emotional intelligence yeah and all
these kind of these newer ideas of how
of of what we could potentially teach as
educate
so yeah interesting because if you think
about that stuff these concepts of
emotional intelligence or empathy right
compassion the science of happiness
maybe you and your audience is not
familiar with this yet but some of you
may be you are
Yale's most popular course last year was
called I think it was called the art of
happy living or the art of a successful
life that was their most popular course
popular course yep and now Berkeley at
you know University California Berkeley
they have a whole Center the I think
it's the I forget the name of it but the
study of happiness right and ironically
it's interesting because if you think
about it that's the stuff that used to
be taught in the spiritual parts of
religion and when you see the
introduction of the really clinical way
of treating religious and subjects which
is needed but you know basically in the
early part of the 20th century we
started to believe that you don't study
society through a religious lens you
study it through a sociological and
through data but that Clint that
clinical approach strips out the
spiritual aspect of what those tough
subjects were seeking to to explore and
now we've kind of replaced or we're
starting to replace the gap of spiritual
education with these sort of more
scientifically driven approaches to
traditionally spiritual topics like
empathy and compassion and human
centricity okay so this is crazy that
the most popular course at Yale was
about happiness in the art of living
that's that's just blowing my mind right
now because I think that's a huge
transition because we we've never had
that until now and that actually in the
West because in the in some places in
the eastern hemisphere it was definitely
more common to have courses taught
especially through religious context
maybe like Buddhism things like this
that just certain aspects of emotion
regulation certain aspects of happiness
of oneness with nature all these
different but I think that we would be
it would be imprudent to omit the
Greek tradition of Education if you
think about Aristotle and Jesuit too was
very polymath that's interesting but the
reason I wanted to bring that up is that
this idea of having subject specific
teachers was not the way that education
always began and you talk about polymath
type of people you know well yeah and I
mean somebody like in the Greek
tradition you had a small group of
people who would be taught by a tutor
like a really smart person like
Aristotle and so it's interesting that
over time we've evolved this model where
only a PhD in economics can teach you
economics 101 and I would question that
if you want to talk about that in a
minute
and when you have a situation where you
are learning from one tutor more you're
learning from somebody who can kind of
weave together the subjects it can
introduce the opportunity for a little
bit more of a holistic education yes
okay so yeah let's definitely stay on
this for a moment so we have both the
kind of multidisciplinary understanding
of knowledge that way maybe a PhD in
econ has built a massive tree in their
mind garden econ Tower which is
fantastic
but then how econ relates to commodities
being traded across the world or how it
relates to right you know couldn't you
know Aristotle in that model can say
listen you can see incredible economic
trade-offs in the balancing of a
beautiful marble Greek sculpture right
because if it's out of balance it falls
apart now look at a market if the bat if
the markets out of balance then that
also falls apart
that's a dot that does that's a node
that is only capable from seeing these
two dots in and presented in this
different way and I think that when you
talk about the structure of higher
education you have to bring in the
question is it necessary that a
researcher teaches is it necessary that
a researcher teaches and what do you
think about them definitely not
particularly in the 101 you know subject
matter
the bulk of people's higher education
experience is learning the basics of a
subject sociology 101 government in
101 econ 101 biology 101 finance 101
right you have to take your course right
and so is it necessary that somebody who
has that tower of econ teaches you econ
101 or is it more necessary that
somebody who can get you excited about
the field of economics teaches you econ
101 it makes it super relatable and fun
and and then you get that in the econ
101 and then you can get a more of a PhD
introduction to it if you so choose to
pursue making a tree yes I would argue
that for master's level and PhD level
students it's necessary that you learn
from a researcher but in the 101 stuff I
don't think that there's really hardly
any reason that you need to learn from
somebody who's a PhD in the subject in
fact a lot of the things now that our
econ 101 English 101 although subject I
mentioned the key learning outcomes and
what the basics are that you need to
have are known we know what the basics
are that a student needs to know what we
really need is somebody who can get that
student's attention and keep it and get
them excited about it and help them
understand how it matters for their life
I think a major you're so spot-on a huge
amount of the educational stress that we
experience in our fabric of education
comes from the lack of excitement of
young people to care about their own
education and I think that does happen
I think a lot of that is actually in the
fault of the parent and then in of
course the fault of the community the
fault of the teachers that kind of stuff
but it there also needs to be some sort
of energy that comes from within the kid
to want to learn so yeah that's the only
important thing it's figuring out how to
get it the inspiration from inside to
learn well also I think the to learning
how to get somebody to care about their
brain and and it comes I do I don't know
the exact let's say logical 50% 50% or
whatever it would end up being I think
that it I think it does have to be in
both places it has
to be from within but there has to be an
exterior community of teacher-parent
environment that fosters the curiosity
to be insatiable as well and so maybe a
good example of this would be when you
have a like you were describing earlier
there's this amazing young teacher that
knows how to the Aristotle from the back
of the day that can bring young people
into groups and inspire them to have a
multidisciplinary approach to knowledge
and get them excited about learning
through experiential learning and all
this cool all this cool stuff and then
they can rock it off into specialties
with different teachers and so we we're
we're a little bit industrialized we're
a little commercialized in terms of our
education and it's kind of fitting a lot
of if ever if every if every human is a
different shape we're trying to fit them
all through the square hole and I think
that that is some fit through the square
hole and I think some fit through
circular triangular and trapezoidal
holes and that's that's that we need to
make those different when you start to
unfortunately commingle the concepts of
education and economic return
unfortunately you get into some
uncomfortable situations that are not
mostly about your whole person instead
it becomes about these other outcomes
primarily economic our slogan here which
is hard to read is plenum vite a the
full life and there's let'em vite a the
full life yes because you know the
science the the research that we have
the best research around from some nobel
prize-winning economists i believe is
that that at Princeton and I forget his
name in the moment but he's basically
shown that at seventy-five thousand
dollars a year in salary average in
America
your ability to be happier through an
additional dollar of income is fully
saturated plateaus happiness plateaus
well it just you won't get any
additional happiness from an additional
dollar so like that that's not to say
that maybe you know you can't spend your
money then moving to somewhere you
prefer or changing a career that you
like but that but your dollar plot your
happiness from an additional dollar
stops so essentially the research shows
that when you make 75 grand a year in
the United States then you have satiated
your ability to become happier through
the money and so it's interesting in
that kind of focus on meaning or purpose
in life
yes partnership who's your who's your
who which humans do you share your life
with yeah how do you achieve something
yourself how do you feel like a sense of
dignity and this is a big question when
you get into you know sort of the desire
to create social institutions that
guarantee certain outcomes is if a
person's outcome is guaranteed then
there's no dignity in achieving the
outcome and so when people are given the
ability to so much of our meeting and
purpose in life comes from putting a
workload on our back to go forth and
achieve that goal so lowly human beings
are made to be challenged we're made to
explore were made to challenge ourselves
and achieve things and that's the beauty
of a full life in an education in that
sense is no longer inserting rote facts
and figures into your brain it's opening
you up to that garden so you can become
the gardener right yeah becoming the
gardener can unpack this more for us you
were wandering us down education
commingled with economics currently in
higher education you hear a lot I'll
give you a specific story that's an
example so we went to this education
conference in San Diego recently to
represent easel and interestingly first
of all the the higher education area was
populated with human resource softwares
and human resource solutions why would
there be human resource softwares and
human resource solutions at a basically
university conference it's because
college degrees have gotten
expensive so when there is when there's
such an element of expense in the
college conversation you now have to
justify that expense right so now that's
what I mean by commingling education
with basically economic return now
colleges are having to justify their
price tag by saying you're gonna earn
more money and while education is in
part about earning more money in fact
it's really about opening your mind to
all these new possibilities and worlds
and so I'm not saying that there's not
an economic return but it's unfortunate
when the only angle that can be
prudently explored when you get into the
conversation of higher education is in
the economic return of that higher
education yeah we're almost excessively
tying economic return to education to
such an extent that it's causing a lot
of corruption and crony capitalism
that's going on within that fabric of
what is a sacred opportunity to expand
the mind of young people and we also
have things like and adults have been
working in blue-collar jobs or like
whatever their situation is and they're
looking to get ahead in life as we get
in the mountain to the knowledge economy
they're going into college to learn
about how this stuff works and I know
that those people are more motivated by
the career elements of a cop of a
college experience but they still even I
would argue that the the honest career
elements of a higher education are
holistic because we all now see more and
more that be teaching somebody to go be
a coder when they don't want to be a
developer when they're not passionate
about technology is is a it's gonna fail
it's not a sustainable trajectory so the
idea it's interesting that you say that
you say that because you know that
there's so many people that are going
into programming right now that don't
even know if their soul is fulfilled
through programming but that's because
it pays 100 K a year yeah I would I
would argue that you have to question is
is that whole theme of people going into
coding
driven by the demand for coders by major
corporations because you know now it's
just accepted that we need more coders
really and I don't agree with that when
we look around our communities I think
we need more coffee shops we need more
construction companies we need more
things that build community people are
starving for third places they're
starving for human interactions but
somehow everybody believes that if
they're not a developer they don't have
any social status and they're not going
to be economically viable and I think
that it's a crime that we've allowed the
conversation to drift so far into the
business needs of technology companies
and I'm not a technology company or not
you're not at all your your your your
interestingly enough bringing in a very
important perspective into the mix of
nuance which is that we have this
massive demand of technology from
business and coding in the sense and
we're like okay great that exists now
the idea isn't to just start funneling
as many people as possible over there as
without even looking at this other side
of things which is that we're starved in
our communities for interpersonal love
and meaning and purpose so how do we
foster that and they are they're good
jobs but they're but the we're also
approaching kind of the automation of a
lot of work in in in in what we can we
can unpack web shop employee or a
business owner it's hard to automate a
restaurant owner it's hard to automate
these things that build community so I
would argue that those are sustainable
drivers of value and actually through
equity crowdfunding which is a
securities law here in the United States
and something that ezel has started to
crack the nut on I believe that small
business is starting to be able to find
an element where you can actually make
pretty good money from owning a small
business you need to do it in a
community oriented way and using
specific laws that enable you to
basically sell shares to the public but
I think that more and more we're going
to see that small business is a
sustainable career path and that you
know development is kind of what you
would call in business strategy a red
ocean opportunity that is that the
developer talent pool is getting
increasingly commoditized because it can
be traded over the web which means it
can be traded all over the world and now
if somebody in the Philippines can Coe
in the same way that you can code and
there in the Philippines they charge $20
an hour and that's a fabulous wage for
them but if you're living in San
Francisco you can't live on $20 an hour
and so you're entering into a dynamic
that's not favorable for you over the
long term okay there's so much to talk
about about economics in education we
were just talking about economics and
ecology yesterday was Steven cutter
quick
yes quick just quick - right before we
get there just the idea that we are
coupling we're now coupling ecology with
economics were coupling education with
economics but we're not prioritizing
economics over ecology or economics over
education it has to co-mingle
it has to Co live the process of of
innovation creativity business
intellectual property globalization
these have to co-mingle and live with
ecology at the same time and not take a
step on it and same thing with education
and in same thing with education in the
study of the human mind being developed
into the world that I was just just
making a general point about when we you
stupid but you know that's kind of a
famous Bill Clinton you know phrases
about the economy stupid I would say
it's about cost stupid why is the
conversation going towards economics in
education it's because it's too
expensive
if stuff is $500 like our undergraduate
degree is going to be then all of a
sudden you're like well I don't care if
it gets me a job that makes me a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars next year I
paid five hundred dollars I can go and
do a boot camp after this degree and
then I will get right into whatever
career field that I want to be in and
then you might have to take another boot
camp in five years to get into another
field that might be the new norm but
when your undergraduate learning
experience cost seventy thousand dollars
then it better be making you money right
out the gate cuz you got to pay back the
money you got to be back let's do this
quick cost analysis this is really
important to address so we have the
normal sort of career path today the
education path that you do after heist
school will either take you into the
workforce into the military into
colleges and when you choose to go into
college what your bet is is that you're
betting that you're gonna earn much more
money over the your lifetime which is
just the true statement that you do
depending depending on what what what
there's so much more nuance to it but
just to get back to the main thesis of
this point so there is a Harvard
education just whatever $200,000 for
four years there's a online education
that you can get through places like
Arizona State University that costs
about seventy thousand dollars so you
can take it from your home but it's
still gonna cost you 70 K $37,000
digitally in the United States $37,000
degree so now this is two orders of
magnitude less almost easels degree 1.5
percent of the national average costs
yes obviously reducing it by almost a
hundred times yes and so now this is a
now now we should we should do a little
bit of unpacking about what easels are
offering in this course but just the
notion that I pay 500 bucks for a four
this is a non-accredited degree but
interestingly enough you can walk into
any job and showcase your skills your
skills and they will your portfolio and
they after an easel degree and they'll
be like whoa how do you know all these
skills when someone else had to pay 50k
for all these skills and they don't even
know you're the way that you teach is so
awesome and you guys will have links in
the bio to check this out definitely
click through and look at this but just
the way that you've added you're
basically doing the thing that Aristotle
was doing in today's digital age you're
taking all of these animations and these
graphics and this voice overlay and
you're making it super fun and and and
visually pleasing and educationally
pleasing yeah I mean we want it to be
like the matrix we want to kind of
program your brain
and the way that we do that is by using
sound effects at the right time by
having definitions on the screen so
you're reading them while a voice is
saying them at the same time now you're
having multiple vectors of information
going into your brain and that's going
to enable you to remember stuff a lot
more quickly and you're gonna go right
from theory to watching somebody do it
to doing it and that means that you're
gonna basically be hands-on in moments
and that's a big deal I love I love the
way that you're explaining this so um
and this is what meant we've had Chester
Santos who's a us memory champion on our
show and he had made it very clear that
the more that you activate other senses
when you're learning information the
better your recall is going to be so
like you said you're getting it visually
you're getting it auditorially
background video so like let's say that
we're introducing a you know idea of
communicating through an online ad and
there's some concept you know
what'swhat's remarketing right so now
you're having the definition of
remarketing on the screen plus
somebody's saying the exact words that
you're reading plus you're seeing
somebody go and see an ad for something
that they saw two seconds ago all of
those things to get your brain all just
absorbing it in the right way you said
something else that's so crucial which
is that now you're not only watching
somebody remark it then you are going
and remarketing yourself right it's an
application right away you're going and
applying your skills see somebody on
screen do it right so now let's go do it
you're gonna watch somebody like me do
it and then it's gonna be like now you
do it here's a step by step to do it and
now you've done it right so so see so
like here see do really fast right into
the stuff that you're doing yes and here
see do is this is a major part of the
future of Education huge part this
experiential learning the doing yeah
definitely I mean I can't argue with
that and I think that what it does is it
transforms our community we have about a
hundred and fifty thousand students now
around the world and it transforms their
relationship with us ezal is not a
paternalistic figure telling you what to
think instead we are a tool that you can
go to for the rest of
your life so you have lifetime access to
all your coursework and so you can
imagine that maybe you don't need your
maybe you don't need to do a
macroeconomic analysis today on a conic
on a country when you're taking your
macroeconomics class but then what
you're doing is you're coming back in
ten years when your boss says I don't
know if we should open stores in Costa
Rica and now you go back to your course
which is all about doing the project the
theory is only there to support the
doing by the way easels been updating
the course over time year after year
yeah for our major courses we update
them every year so you know that it's
fresh and you go back and you're like
okay I need to do a macroeconomic
analysis now and now you do it at work
ten years after you earned your degree
so instead of you having to feel like
you have to know everything and be able
to do it right now that's not natural
that's not how we operate anymore we
have the internet so now you know that
you have these resources but now you
have the good resources and you know
where they are that's the primary value
of easel is that we've curated it for
you it's so ridiculous that I'm not able
to go back to the University was made
like you said to be this massive place
of data and collection of knowledge and
wisdom and I don't why can't I go now in
the digital age and just go tap into the
University today and I can go and pull
some great coursework it might suck you
know it might suck because if you went
back and you took your economics if I
went back and I took my macroeconomics
class which would cost four thousand
bucks
yeah and I took it from my my alma mater
Sonoma State in California then I would
get pure theory about economics about
macro economics about you know monetary
supply and all that stuff and while
that's neat and it does raise my
cognitive ceiling it doesn't help me do
very much and so it's a little bit
different to have lifetime access to a
learning experience that is purely
calibrated to doing something versus
just reading in the textbook you're also
doing you're not just taking tests but
you're also doing and it's not quizzes
right these are actual things that are
useful and I think that the use
should drive your knowledge for a lot of
people you need to go in especially at
the undergraduate level and get your
hands into it see what you like that's a
big problem with education now is that
people get so wrapped up in studying
these very tiny nuances of subjects that
basically it only trains you to be a
professor it only trains you to be a
professor and the multidisciplinary
approach to knowledge is just immensely
crucial for a foundation for a child I I
tend to think that and writing a lot
about that right now okay so let's let's
make sure we talk about this so as you
get this lifetime ability to go back and
tap into the newest courses that are
being made by you guys and the give us a
quick on the we should definitely talk
on about the the fact that your your
accreditation of easil when you go and
you go and get easel when that is then
logged on a blockchain that way at any
point you're on a ledger and you're
digitally on the ledger that you've
accomplished these courses that you are
that you've that you've your ability
certain tracks yeah it's about smart
contracts and words this is something
we're building for the future I have to
reiterate that easel primarily our goal
is to make equal opportunity a real
thing because it's total [ __ ] that
this is this idea that there's equal
opportunity in America I would argue
that in across the world I would argue
that in many ways undergraduate
education is the beginning of income
inequality in the United States it's the
very first time that a young person
actually becomes income unequal correct
which means at literally after high
school which you can get a public
education at that point you cannot go to
the school to go learn what you want
because it costs so the person of
privilege goes through that experience
with no debt and then they can allocate
any of the money that they make after
college to whatever their dream is and
then the person who doesn't have
privilege will be paying that off for
the next 20 years and they're forced
into career paths that
may not like right so it's the literal
beginning of income inequality and so I
wanted to bring that up there because
like ezel is is while we are building
for the future and the blockchain is
important our primary goal is to make
higher education accessible for
everybody but when we talk about the
blockchain the reason that it is
important and it is an important point
of access is because of the future of
decentralized organizations and when you
start to have decentralized
organizations that are run on through
digital connection through the
blockchain for example then we believe
that there's going to be a time in the
future where a smart contract will want
to verify whether or not you have a
certain credential and that's what we're
building for is to make sure that you
know if a smart contract says hey Alan
do you have video skills and it's like
yep Alan has video skills he can come in
and apply to work on this or however the
smart contract is going to work that's
huge so I'm taking these did the
different course work and then I'm
accredited in that coursework and then
when I apply for a smart contract it
sees that I'm accredited there and that
I can go and do that work now okay good
I'm glad we touched on that now just
give us a quick round on 150,000
students across the world that's amazing
five hundred dollars to get a
Disciplinary degree now can you go
through the the disciplines that you
guys offer yeah I mean it's this is a
Business School basically so yeah right
now we've been teaching it kind of the
master's level which would say I need to
do Twitter ads now I need to learn how
to negotiate now we have those type of
courses that have been very successful
and then the undergraduate degree
program we're developing is a
well-rounded business education and I
focus on well-rounded because there are
two out of the five sections that are
not purely driven by economics and
finance they are things like this is
just all sorts of things about the
science of happiness the relationship we
call like ethno biology the
relationships of human beings to the
earth things like sociology we want to
give some we want to have a something
that that offers a well-rounded
education for people the full life is
our goal so so you're you've made it
very clear that knowing how to do you
know Twitter ads now
equally as important as having a
connection to other humans and that
that's it's so so important there
they're actually quite a bit of overlaps
between those two we reframe things a
lot of times in terms of human
centricity everything for us is about
human beings and so if you're gonna be
advertising on Twitter you need to know
that there's another human being on the
other side of that screen or your ad is
gonna suck if you're gonna create
something if we create a product or
service we want you to think about the
person that's using that immediately so
as as as many times as we can we're
trying to fight against this idea that
human beings don't matter
human beings are currently the gods of
the earth and you have to realize that
we are going to structure the world for
other human beings that's the only way
we're gonna do it because we are the
species that drives the development and
the evolution of the entire planet and
in the future of space that's exactly
right so fortunate to have evolved here
and to now be in control and we didn't
really even realize it's a tremendous
responsibility and we we didn't even
really realize that we were gaining
control and now we're like oh crap we're
in control and it's like we can't
pollute the crap out of it we have to
actually sustain it over time when we
have to actually maximize the potential
the species to become interplanetary and
all this other good stuff okay that's
been good this was in great breakdown I
think we've covered almost almost
everything that we really wanted to
cover I think something else on the way
out that we should talk about is in
general the future of Education we've
been talking about it a lot right now
I think throughout this we've been
talking about it but I think especially
with the onset of an advent of
technologies like artificial
intelligence it's kind of changing the
future of work the future of human
capital the future of Education now it's
becoming more and more important for
children to have robot proof skills to
develop these skills so go ahead and
teach us about like what do you think
about this gig economy what do you think
about the future of Education yeah you
better make it about humans if you make
it about humans you're going to be
sustainable human beings are the
heartbeat of our experience
and tell us more about making it
human-centric
well you know I think like many
technological experiences I've had
there's a lot of technologies that are
hammers looking for a nail I'm not fully
bought in to the value of artificial
intelligence for the last mile of value
creation I think that for places like
Facebook that have oodles of data and
self-driving cars that need to mine
doodles of data constantly then
artificial intelligence is very helpful
but if you think about the things that
matter to you in your life mostly it's
like eating healthy food it's having a
nice partner it's having a successful
family it's being able to make enough
money to pay your bills and to travel a
little bit and if you look at the price
of almost all goods and services on the
planet they're plummeting the only
things that are raising in price are
things that are associated with status
and in general at easel we think that
status is total [ __ ] and it's a it's
a manipulation on the people I'm gonna
go ahead and take this opportunity to do
a little bit of virtual signalling
virtual signalling is not a bad thing
it's actually something that's developed
with evolutionary psychology commingled
with it along the path virtue signaling
meaning that when when we say things
when you and I say things like we don't
believe in status symbols like having to
wear massive gold chains or diamonds and
and having yachts and all this stuff
when we say those things we don't say it
because oh we're just too poor to afford
it no we just say it because we think
that it's a major distraction away from
the human-centric
values what the heck do you need a gold
chain around your neck for I mean and
I'm not stopping anybody for whom that's
a big deal but if that's going to steer
your life then I think that you should
reflect on that in general and so when
you look at the cost of airplane tickets
I mean I was just watching The Godfather
to the other night and Michael
Corleone's sister has to come to beg him
for a ship passage to Europe they want
to take a ship to Europe right used to
be so expensive now I mean you can get
to Europe for $400 from most places
I mean Airbnb has you Burt all of these
things have lowered the cost of
traditionally luxurious thing that the
definition
disruptive business practices so things
and experiences are relatively
inexpensive what's in short supply is
your values and how you look at the
world and looking at the world through a
healthy lens that's about human beings
and being kind and doing things that are
sustainable and things that matter and
so for me if artificial intelligence how
is a part of that equation that's fine
but I don't really see that being
disruptive to the last mile of value
delivery in general and I'm talking
about you know experiences like going
out into nature staying in hotels having
food that you that delicious food that
in experiences that you like going to
the coffee shop reading about ideas
experiencing culture learning a lot of
that stuff is made by humans so just
keep focusing on the humans and you'll
be fine and you know for most people
yeah I hope that they can get into
government regimes that are going to be
conducive to that that because I we do
have a real global perspective at easel
our students are everywhere and so you
know the only time that you can get
forded having that mindset is if you're
in an unfortunate situation where you're
you know the people in power are
restricting that type of thing I agree
with you so much about human centricity
being at the center of prosperity what
is prosperity you know because god I
just in the same movie last night you
know I'm watching Vito Corleone's a
young guy he comes in to give his wife a
gift and put it on the table and it was
you know a nice thing for her to get it
was a pair one pair right and like today
we go to the grocery store and we buy so
many pairs that they rot we forget about
the context that we're in we are also
blessed and so and I'm not saying that
from a religious standpoint but like
just imagine the abundance were
surrounded by it is fabulous you you are
really on point with the way that you're
making it clear that it used to be a
major deal to take a boat across
continents and now it's a quick plane
ticket that's much cheaper you taking a
taxi used to be a luxury now it's just
an uber
right away and and so I think that the
way that this applies to human
centricity is the more that we focus on
the more we focus on our community's
development and the fostering of really
powerful experiences for humans to have
with each other for people to be self
actualized into the world to have real
true equality of opportunity for people
competitive advantage this is not about
you being selfless
from my perspective from my perspective
this is a sustainable economic worldview
yes exactly
correct and it really it has to be
coupled a sustainable economic worldview
with the notion of of prosperity these
things have to be coupled together you
have to create and give value to others
for other human beings to value you
that's the fundamental of an economic
exchange of a voluntary transaction
right is that you have created something
that somebody voluntarily wishes to give
you money for and so if they're not
gonna give you money for things that
help you out they give you money for
things that help them out this is a
classic balance between selflessness and
selfishness the ego and the ego less and
that is crucial to strike as we move
forward i we've covered so much I feel
very enriched I feel very blessed to
have had the opportunity to talk to you
about yeah I can't I can't help but
introduce that you know in a time when
religion is on the run in the United
States and around the world in general I
mean I think especially in the developed
world religion and people calling
themselves religious is going down and
down and down but there are beautiful
values to be found in the in what we've
seen from history and I'm not promoting
any religious ideology at all or Dogma
but if you think about like there's a
the Catholics have this value of Caritas
they call it a cardinal virtue and the
securedoc Caritas means love of the
stranger right and that is that is the
heartbeat it's the
lifeblood of a economically sustainable
prosperous healthy worldview is that you
value people that you don't know even to
the point that you love them and if you
do that if everybody followed a morality
like that then there wouldn't be the
violence and the corruption and the
greed well it washes away the other
nests I believe that the other that moat
so I believe that a lies Plato did that
every action has a good intent in in its
in its origination that there's no pure
evil in the world there is just
confusion and most of the confusion
comes from other nakhon cept of that
there is another apart from me and so as
you wash away that idea of the other and
you embrace these ideas of human
centricity providing value for others
you're going to be just fine and very
happy what a beautiful way to end thank
you so much for this conversation for
enriching us I feel like the lens with
which we see the world has been
augmented I think that the garden that
we're gonna be growing with flowers and
trees in it we're gonna figure out how
to plant seeds and water them over time
and more effective ways I'm really
excited for that definitely check out
link in the bio for easel code
definitely go check them out
we'll have maybe a discount link
potentially well if some simulation
peeps can get a discount to go try out
some of the easel courses again this is
really important to to take into account
that this is kind of where we're heading
it's not gonna be so much the massive
conglomerates that are limiting and
throttling the knowledge but also
propelling it but that we're gonna have
a decentralized and more of a a colorful
approach to the way that we do education
moving forward if you guys had a good
time definitely not only check out easel
but also go share with other people what
you learned here go share with
people have them share with two people
let's spread the message let's keep the
word going comment with your thoughts
below let's start a little community
chat subscribe join us on patreon so we
continue sustaining this and bringing it
out to more people around the world and
Davis thanks so much for joining us and
greatly appreciate it awesome thanks
everyone